This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Nearly a year ago, we ran an episode about one of the world's most intractable divides, the Israeli-Palestinian conflict. Since that story aired, a solution to the conflict seems ever more out of reach. Israelis and Palestinians are closely following the case of an Israeli soldier convicted of manslaughter in the death of a Palestinian. He did back off from the idea of a two-state solution, a Palestinian conflict as a fight over history. A Palestinian drove a truck into a crowd of Israeli soldiers, according to Israeli
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦。将近一年前，我们播放了一期关于世界上最棘手的鸿沟之一——巴以冲突的节目。自那篇报道播出以来，解决冲突的方案似乎更加遥不可及。以色列人和巴勒斯坦人都在密切关注一名以色列士兵因过失杀害一名巴勒斯坦人而被定罪的案件。他确实退出了两国方案的想法，这是一场将巴勒斯坦冲突视为关于历史争端的斗争。据以色列
police. At least four people are dead and 15 in the same way. This episode offers a perspective we don't often hear and news about the conflict. Compassion for the other side. I think that the two big elements that are lacking from the discourse on both sides is one massive lack of hope and two this unbelievable lack of empathy. This kind of empathy for your enemy is difficult and dangerous. What was most hurtful for me, most painful, was nobody stood by me. But this empathy can also be something else, powerful.
警方称，一名巴勒斯坦人驾驶卡车撞向一群以色列士兵。至少有四人死亡，15人受伤。本期节目提供了一个我们在关于冲突的新闻中不常听到的视角：对另一方的同情。我认为，双方论述中缺失的两个大要素，一是极其缺乏希望，二是极其缺乏同情心。这种对敌人的同情是困难且危险的。对我而言，最伤人、最痛苦的是没有人站在我身边。但这种同情也可以是另一种强大的力量。
It can accomplish remarkable things, it can change minds and bring down walls. And I'm staring at this wall of the window of the bus at the Kalandia checkpoint. And six million ghosts chase me as we drive through. And I wonder if they will ever rest. So my name is Avaner Gvaryahu, I'm 31 actually today. Growing up Avaner Gvaryahu was a model Israeli patriot. I grew up in a religious family, what we call religious nationalist family, and I went to a religious high school, what we call in Hebrew or Yashiva.
它能完成非凡的事情，能改变思想，能推倒高墙。我正盯着卡兰迪亚检查站公交车窗外的这堵墙。当我们驶过时，六百万个幽灵追随着我。我在想他们是否能安息。我叫阿夫纳·格瓦里亚.胡，今天我31岁了。在成长过程中，阿夫纳·格瓦里亚胡是一个模范的以色列爱国者。我在一个宗教家庭长大，也就是我们所说的宗教民族主义家庭，我读了一所宗教高中，我们在希伯来语中称之为耶希瓦。
I joined the army when I was 19 after doing a year of community service and I served for three years as a paratrooper and a special ops unit. Being a soldier came naturally to Avner. In my society, in my community, and in my family as well, you know, this was something that was discussed often. I'm named after a soldier who was killed in 1973 in the Yom Kippur War. My dad himself was a paratrooper. My older brother was a combat soldier. The people around me, my mentors, my teachers, my counselors and my youth movements were all, of course, in the military.
我在做了一年社区服务后于19岁参军，作为一名伞兵和特种作战队员服役了三年。当兵对阿夫纳来说是很自然的事。在我的社会里，在我的社区里，也在我的家庭里，你知道，这是经常被讨论的事情。我的名字是以一个在1973年赎罪日战争中阵亡的士兵命名的。我父亲本人就是一名伞兵。我哥哥是一名作战士兵。我周围的人，我的导师、我的老师、我的辅导员和我的青年运动成员，当然都曾在军队服役。
So I was really waiting for my chance to go and protect my country and serve. That was sort of something that I always knew I would do and I wanted to be, you know, the best I could be at that. But early in his military service, Avnare started to see things that challenged his worldview. He was often asked to pull a maneuver known as a straw widow. This involved entering a Palestinian home to use the windows on the upper floors to cover other Israeli soldiers carrying out operations on the street. So I found myself numerous cases throughout my service invading people's homes in the middle of the night, most of the time, after we knew that the people inside these homes
所以我真的很期待我的机会去保护我的国家和服役。这算是我一直知道自己会做的事，我也想成为，你知道的，在这方面做到最好。但在他军旅生涯的早期，阿夫纳开始看到一些挑战他世界观的事情。他经常被要求执行一种被称为“稻草寡妇”的战术。这涉及到进入巴勒斯坦人的家中，利用高层的窗户来掩护在街上执行任务的其他以色列士兵。因此，在我服役期间的许多案例中，我发现自己在半夜入侵人们的家，大多数情况下，是在我们知道这些房子里的人
were innocent. Because you do not want to enter someone's house if you know that he's involved in some terrorist organization. So what we actually did is you find a house on a map. You choose the house because it's situated in the right place, because it's elevated enough, because it has the right size windows, and you enter this house in the middle of the night. Now, this house, from that moment on, belongs to the soldiers, right?
是无辜的之后。因为你不想进入别人的房子，如果你知道他参与了某个恐怖组织的话。所以我们实际上做的是在地图上找一处房子。你选择这栋房子是因为它的位置合适，因为它足够高，因为它有合适大小的窗户，然后在半夜进入这栋房子。现在，从那一刻起，这栋房子就属于士兵了，对吧？
If the family wants to use the bathroom or the kitchen, in many cases they need permission from the soldiers. Of course, the family can't leave their house. And this dynamic between soldiers and Palestinians was something that I was part of for many, many nights. And I think that that's where I really learned for the first time, first of all, a little bit about the Palestinians, because I was never in a Palestinian home before I started my service. I had no real contacts with Palestinians before I started my service. But also, I learned about the power dynamic that I was part of.
如果家人想用卫生间或厨房，在很多情况下他们需要得到士兵的许可。当然，家人不能离开他们的房子。士兵和巴勒斯坦人之间的这种动态是我很多个夜晚经历的一部分。我认为这也是我第一次真正了解巴勒斯坦人，因为在我开始服役之前，我从未进过巴勒斯坦人的家。在我开始服役之前，我与巴勒斯坦人没有任何真正的接触。但同时，我也了解了我所处的权力动态。
Just the fact that I was born sort of in the right side of the green line. Just the fact that I was born to an Israeli Jewish family gave me the power to walk in with a helmet, with a gun, with my uniform, and I was in control of an entire family. One night in particular, it stands out in his memory. We were supposed to take over our house, and we were walking through the open space around the house. We made maybe too much noise, or maybe we stepped on the branch,
仅仅因为我出生在绿线的正确一边。仅仅因为我出生在一个以色列犹太人家庭，我就拥有了戴着头盔、拿着枪、穿着制服走进这里的权力，并且我控制了一整个家庭。特别是有一个晚上，在他的记忆中格外清晰。我们本应接管一栋房子，我们正走在房子周围的开阔地上。我们可能制造了太大的噪音，或者我们踩断了树枝，
and we started hearing screaming from inside a Palestinian home. So me and the officer who were leading our soldiers went up to the window where we hear the screams because we could be detected and that's not something we want. And we break the glass of this house and we peer in with our rifles. We had flashlights on the barrels. And we see on the floor of this house an older lady, an elderly lady, helpless. And she was on the floor, I don't know what exactly happened, maybe she heard us and she was petrified and she just fell off her bed. I remember looking to the other side of the room and I could see at the end of the corridor some people or voices and it was her family who were petrified to come and help her. I remember standing there and telling myself, this is not what I thought I would be doing. This is definitely not promoting the security of my country or the security of my family.
我们开始听到巴勒斯坦人家中传出的尖叫声。所以我和带领我们士兵的军官走到我们听到尖叫声的窗户前，因为我们可能会被发现，这不是我们希望看到的。我们打破了这间房子的玻璃，用步枪向内窥视。我们的枪管上带着手电筒。我们看到这间房子的地板上有一位年长的女士，一位老妇人，无依无靠。她倒在地上，我不知道具体发生了什么，也许她听到了我们的声音，吓坏了，从床上摔了下来。我记得看着房间的另一头，我可以看到走廊尽头有一些人或听到声音，那是她的家人，他们吓得不敢过来帮她。我记得站在那里对自己说，这可不是我想象中自己在做的事。这绝对不是在促进我国家的安全，也不是在促进我家庭的安全。
And I started thinking, what about the family of this old lady? I mean, what do they think about me now? Moments like this are what prompted Avanair to start working with an organization called Breaking the Silence, a group of military veterans who want to talk openly about what they've learned. From Avnars perspective, there's nothing unpatriotic about Israeli veterans telling their stories, talking about moments they struggle with, or Palestinian families they got to know. But others see it differently. Some see it as treason. In one recent video, a group targeting
我开始思考，这位老妇人的家人呢？我的意思是，他们现在怎么看我？这样的时刻促使阿夫纳开始与一个名为“打破沉默”的组织合作，这是一群想要公开谈论他们所学所知的退伍军人。从阿夫纳的角度来看，以色列退伍军人讲述他们的故事、谈论他们挣扎的时刻或他们结识的巴勒斯坦家庭，并没有什么不爱国的地方。但其他人有不同的看法。有些人认为这是叛国。最近的一段视频中，一个针对
Avnare shows a Palestinian attacking in Israeli with a knife. The video then accuses four human rights activists, including Avnare, of protecting the terrorists. They called all four of us foreign agents or what they called it were stulim, which basically means implanted, meaning my opinions, my thoughts, and the actions of myself and my friends are not things we actually think on our own, but we're actually working for foreign government. To us it sounded that if they're actually working for, um, uh, foreign government. Um, to us, it
阿夫纳的组织展示了一名巴勒斯坦人用刀袭击以色列人的画面。视频随后指责包括阿夫纳在内的四名人权活动人士保护恐怖分子。他们称我们四人为外国代理人，或者他们称之为stulim，这基本上意味着被植入者，这意味着我的观点、我的想法以及我和朋友们的行为并不是我们自己真正思考的结果，而是我们在为外国政府工作。在我们听来，如果他们实际上是在为、嗯、嗯，外国政府工作。嗯，在我们听来，这
sounded that if they're blaming us for being spies. As I was listening to Avner, I couldn't stop thinking about a study I read many years ago. Psychologist Lee Ross ran an experiment at Stanford University. He brought in students from a pro-Israeli group and a pro-Arab group and had them watch television news clips about the Arab-Israeli conflict. He found the pro-Israeli group and a pro-Arab group and had them watch television news clips about the Arab-Israeli conflict. He found the pro-Israeli students saw lots of anti-Israel references in the news clips, whereas the pro-Arab students saw lots of anti-Arab references while looking at the very same news clips.
听起来就像是在指责我们是间谍。当我听阿夫纳说话时，我不禁想起多年前我读过的一项研究。心理学家利·罗斯在斯坦福大学做了一个实验。他找来了亲以色列团体和亲阿拉伯团体的学生，让他们观看关于阿以冲突的电视新闻片段。他发现，亲以色列的学生在新闻片段中看到了很多反以色列的引用，而亲阿拉伯的学生在看完全相同的片段时，看到了很多反阿拉伯的引用。
When Arabs in Israelis think about their conflict, each group desperately wants observers to know that they have been wronged. To acknowledge the pain on the other side is to somehow limit this claim. That's why two groups can look at the same reality and see completely different things. I told Avner, his story reminded me of the study. As you're telling me the story, I'm realizing that one of the psychological implications of your work is that really when you try and empathize with what the other side is going through, there is something about that action that drives your friends and comrades really angry. That the idea that one of you would empathize with the other side feels like betrayal.
当阿拉伯人和以色列人思考他们的冲突时，每个群体都迫切希望观察者知道他们受到了委屈。承认另一方的痛苦在某种程度上就是限制这种主张。这就是为什么两个群体可以看着同一现实却看到完全不同的东西。我告诉阿夫纳，他的故事让我想起了这项研究。当你给我讲这个故事时，我意识到你的工作的心理学含义之一是，当你试图去共情另一方的遭遇时，这种行为本身会激起你的朋友和同志的极大的愤怒。那种你们当中有人会去共情另一方的想法感觉就像是背叛。
Yeah, I think that you're touching a point which is true and I think is extremely difficult. You know, silence is not an Israeli disease, it's not an Israeli epidemic. There is no society, there is no community that does not live with this disease of silence. A big part of what breaking the silence and saying is, you know, the fact that we are talking about our actions, of course it doesn't mean there's no responsibility on the Palestinian side. But you know, when I do think about what can create change and who has the power for change, I can't ignore the fact that in this specific point,
是的，我认为你触及了一个真实且极其困难的点。你知道，沉默不是以色列的疾病，它不是以色列的流行病。没有哪个社会、没有哪个群体不带着这种沉默的疾病生活。“打破沉默”及其言论很大一部分在于，你知道，我们谈论我们的行为，当然这并不意味着巴勒斯坦方面没有责任。但你知道，当我思考是什么能创造改变以及谁拥有改变的力量时，我无法忽视这样一个事实：在特定的一点上，
we are the ones with the power. When we come back, a Palestinian professor tries to get his students to empathize with Israelis. If you learn about the suffering of the other, would that help in your attitude for reconciliation? Stay with us. The psychologist Michael Wall and Nyla Branscom once asked Jewish volunteers to think about
我们才是拥有权力的人。稍后回来，一位巴勒斯坦教授试图让他的学生去共情以色列人。如果你了解了对方的苦难，这会有助于你建立和解的态度吗？请继续收听。心理学家迈克尔·沃尔和奈拉·布兰斯科姆曾让犹太志愿者思考
the suffering of Palestinians. The psychologists reminded some of the volunteers about the Holocaust. Compared to others, Jews reminded of their own group suffering, showed less compassion toward Palestinian suffering. The same thing happens with other groups. Americans reminded of traumas, even distant traumas like the Pearl Harbor attack, show less empathy for victims of torture carried out by American service members. Trauma makes us turn inward.
巴勒斯坦人的苦难。心理学家向部分志愿者提醒了大屠杀。与其他被提醒的人相比，被提醒自己群体苦难的犹太人对巴勒斯坦人的苦难表现出更少的同情。其他群体身上也会发生同样的事情。被提醒经历过创伤的美国人，甚至是像珍珠港袭击这样遥远的创伤，对遭受美国军人虐待的受害者的同情也会减少。创伤使我们转向内向。
It creates justifications for the harm we cause other groups. It makes it harder to feel empathy for our enemies. In 1948, hundreds of thousands of Palestinians lost their homes during the creation of the state of Israel. Palestinians have a word to describe this trauma. They call it the Nakba, the catastrophe. Just as traumatized Israelis don't want to think about the Nakba, traumatized Palestinians, don't want to think about the Nakba, traumatized Palestinians, don't want to think about the Holocaust.
它为我们对其他群体造成的伤害提供了正当理由。它让我们更难对敌人产生同情。1948年，在以色列国建立期间，成千上万的巴勒斯坦人失去了家园。巴勒斯坦人有一个词来描述这种创伤。他们称之为“纳克巴”，即大灾难。正如受创伤的以色列人不想去想“纳克巴”一样，受创伤的巴勒斯坦人也不想去想大屠杀。
Muhammad Dajjani used to be one of those Palestinians who struggled to empathize with Israelis. He considered himself a nationalist. In fact, as a result of his political work for Palestinian statehood, Muhammad says he was forced into exile from his native Jerusalem. He was allowed to return in 1993 because his father was very sick. And then, just like Aufnir, something happened to Muhammad that shook his beliefs about his enemy. In the beginning, it was very difficult for me to adjust. But my father, what cancer, started taking me
穆罕默德·达贾尼曾经是那些难以共情以色列人的巴勒斯坦人之一。他认为自己是一个民族主义者。事实上，由于他为巴勒斯坦建国所做的政治工作，穆罕默德说他被驱逐出他的故乡耶路撒冷。他于1993年被允许返回，因为他的父亲病得很重。然后，就像阿夫纳一样，穆罕默德身上发生了一件事，动摇了他对敌人的看法。起初，我很难适应。但我的父亲得了癌症，开始带我
to an incarium hospital where he used to have chemotherapy. And it made me observe my enemy, the Israelis, the doctors, the nurses, the staff. I noticed that their attitude to my father was not an attitude of an enemy to his enemy but rather a doctor to his patient. Another time, Muhammad's mother suffered a heart attack. He was in a car with her, his brother was driving. We were coming to the Mengorian airport exit and my brother decided to take that exit.
去一家卡里姆医院，他以前在那里接受化疗。这让我观察我的敌人——以色列人、医生、护士和工作人员。我注意到他们对父亲的态度不是敌人对敌人的态度，而是医生对病人的态度。还有一次，穆罕默德的母亲突发心脏病。他和母亲坐在一辆车里，他哥哥在开车。我们来到蒙戈里安机场的出口，我哥哥决定走那个出口。
Muhammad told his brother he was being foolish. Israeli soldiers would stop them, harass them. Muhammad's brother said they had no choice. He pulled up at a security gate. When we came to the gates of the airport, the enemy brother told them that we have a secroman with us and they saw her. They vacated one of the gates there and immediately called for ambulance there when the doctors came.
穆罕默德告诉他哥哥他太愚蠢了。以色列士兵会拦住他们，骚扰他们。穆罕默德的哥哥说他们别无选择。他把车开到了一个安全大门前。当我们来到机场大门时，我兄弟告诉他们我们车里有一个重病人，他们看到了她。他们腾出了那里的一扇门，并立刻叫了救护车，医生们赶了过来。
They found out that they cannot move her so they tried to restate her there so it became like an operation room. These experiences changed Muhammad. He says he stopped thinking of the conflict in terms of Palestinians versus Israelis and started thinking in terms of the Palestinians and Israelis who were four peace and the Palestinians and Israelis who were against peace. And for the very first time he says he tried to see the Palestinian Israeli conflict from the Israeli point of view. He began teaching political science at Al-Qudz University in Jerusalem, and he brought his new understanding with him.
他们发现无法挪动她，于是试图在那里对她进行心肺复苏，所以这里变得像一个手术室。这些经历改变了穆罕默德。他说他不再用巴勒斯坦人对阵以色列人的角度来思考冲突，而是开始从赞成和平的巴勒斯坦人和以色列人、以及反对和平的巴勒斯坦人和以色列人的角度来思考。他说，这是他第一次试图从以色列人的角度来看待巴以冲突。他开始在耶路撒冷圣城大学教授政治科学，并将他的新理解带了进去。
But his students couldn't relate. They hadn't had encounters with kind Israeli soldiers and carrying Jewish doctors. In order to come to the university, they used to go through many checkpoints, so they would leave something like three in the morning to get to the university at nine. Muhammad tried to get his students to see beyond the soldiers they met at checkpoints every day. The university set up an Israeli studies program and an American studies program and he started to broach a topic most Palestinians had never encountered at school, the Holocaust. But Muhammad students consumed as they were with their own trauma, could not or would not
但他的学生无法产生共鸣。他们没有遇到过善良的以色列士兵和充满爱心的犹太医生。为了去大学，他们必须穿过许多检查站，所以他们通常早上三点左右出门，九点才能到达大学。穆罕默德试图让他的学生看到他们每天在检查站遇到的士兵之外的人。大学设立了一个以色列研究项目和一个美国研究项目，他开始涉足大多数巴勒斯坦人在学校从未接触过的话题——大屠杀。但穆罕默德的学生们沉浸在他们自己的创伤中，不能或不愿
listen. One of his students was a young woman named Hanan. From Ahamad students, consumed as they were with their own trauma, could not or would not listen. One of his students was a young woman named Hanan. And she was in Israeli presence for nine years. So to her, she looked at what happened with Jews, in Auschwitz, in Krakow and different, uh, Bakanow and different, uh, concentration camps, as if transmitting that to her own experience being a prisoner in Israeli jails and being discriminated against as a woman. Muhammad told Hanan she had constructed a prison inside her own mind, a prison that
倾听。他的学生之一是一个名叫哈南的年轻女性。穆罕默德的学生们沉浸在他们自己的创伤中，不能或不愿倾听。他的学生之一是一个名叫哈南的年轻女性。她在以色列监狱里待了九年。因此，对于她来说，她把犹太人在奥斯威辛、克拉科夫以及不同的比克瑙和不同的集中营里发生的事情，视为将那种经历转移到她自己作为以色列监狱囚犯并作为女性受到歧视的亲身经历中。穆罕默德告诉哈南，她在自己内心的思想中建造了一座监狱，一座
kept her from seeing the world, from the point of view of her enemy. When nothing worked with the students, Muhammad decided he would take Hanan and a couple dozen other students on a field trip to Europe. They would visit Nazi concentration camps and learn, first hand, about the trauma at the heart of the Israeli Jewish experience. It was a scientific project to study about empathy, about if you learn about the suffering of the other, would that help more in your attitude for reconciliation?
让她无法从敌人的角度看待世界的监狱。当对学生们什么都不起作用时，穆罕默德决定带哈南和其他几十名学生去欧洲进行一次实地考察。他们将参观纳粹集中营，第一手了解以色列犹太人体验核心的创伤。这是一个关于同理心的科学项目，研究如果你了解了另一方的苦难，这是否会更有助于你对和解的态度？
We decided to take these 30 Palestinians, children's torches and Krakow in Poland. Almost immediately, there was trouble. So I received an email from the president of the university. He said that I heard rumors that you are taking students' washwets. And I would like you to make it very clear to them that the university has nothing to do with this trip. Another student came to me and said,
我们决定带这30名巴勒斯坦人去波兰的集中营和克拉科夫。几乎立刻，麻烦就来了。我收到了大学校长发来的一电子邮件。他说我听到谣言说你带着学生去奥斯威辛了。我希望你向他们明确表示，学校与这次旅行毫无关系。另一个学生来找我，说
you should cancel this trip, and that if you would go once you come back, you might be facing a very big threat. Mohamed did not waver. He was an educator, and like Avnair, he believed he was being a patriot. Empathy he had come to believe was the only way to understanding and to peace. When they got to Auschwitz, Muhammad and
你应该取消这次旅行，如果你去了，回来之后你可能会面临巨大的威胁。穆罕默德没有动摇。他是一名教育家，和阿夫纳一样，他相信自己是一名爱国者。他渐渐相信，同理心是通往理解和和平的唯一途径。当他们到达奥斯威辛时，穆罕默德和
Hanan stopped at the entrance to the camp. Hanan when she saw the at the entrance, there was like a blackout saying, Arbite-Macht-Frey. So, work sets you free. So, she was very surprised with that slogan on the aggregate of the Auschwitz camp and asked me about it and I said, why don't you lock it up? Hanan learned the meaning of the cynical phrase. The Jewish prisoners who entered this camp were not set free by work.
哈南在集中营入口处停了下来。哈南当她看到入口处时，有一个黑色的标语，上面写着“Arbeit macht frei”（劳动带来自由）。所以，她对奥斯威辛集中营大门上的这个口号感到非常惊讶，并向我询问，我说，你为什么不查一下呢？哈南了解了这个讽刺短语的含义。进入这个集中营的犹太人并没有通过劳动获得自由。
They were worked to death or killed. There was this big room which had toilets and we were told that every morning more than 2,000 people gathered in front of the room and then they make them go through there to use it and they are given 10 seconds to use it and then they have to leave. And so it was such a humiliation for the individual. They were things they never heard of in terms of how human beings were humiliated and broken. As they walked through the camp, Muhammad noticed that Hanan and the other students
他们是被劳累致死或被杀害的。这里有一个很大的房间，里面有厕所，我们被告知每天早上有两000多人在房间前面聚集，然后他们让他们穿过去使用它，他们只有10秒钟的使用时间，之后必须离开。这对个人来说是一种极大的羞辱。这些是他们从未听说过的事情，关于人类是如何被羞辱和击垮的。当他们穿过集中营时，穆罕默德注意到哈南和其他学生
were no longer seeing the Holocaust through the lens of their own suffering. They were actually empathizing with Jews, their enemies. were no longer seeing the Holocaust through the lens of their own suffering. They were actually empathizing with Jews, their enemies. It was very emotional to them, one of the, and some of the girls even cried. One of the students was telling me, I thought that Hitler gathered Jews in these concentration camps to send them to Palestine, to have them shipped to Palestine. So to them, they had total misconception about what is the Holocaust, what is the concentration camp, what did it mean, how life was there, and so it was an open-air for them. But back at home, Muhammad's colleagues at the university
不再透过他们自己苦难的有色眼镜来看待大屠杀。他们实际上是在与他们的敌人——犹太人共情。不再透过他们自己苦难的有色眼镜来看待大屠杀。他们实际上是在与他们的敌人——犹太人共情。这对他们来说非常触动，其中一些女孩甚至哭了起来。其中一个学生告诉我，我以为希特勒把犹太人聚集在这些集中营里是为了把他们送到巴勒斯坦，把他们运送到巴勒斯坦。所以对他们来说，他们对什么是大屠杀、什么是集中营、它意味着什么、那里的生活是怎样的，有着完全错误的观念，所以这对他们来说是一次开眼界的经历。但回到家中，穆罕默德在大学里的同事
did not see the trip as an invaluable educational experience. The last day in Auschwitz, my secretary, wrote to me an email saying that students have come in the Rens Actor office and they were made, they are making demonstrations against your own campus and that they came and left you a letter of threatening your life that you should not come back to the university and that if you come back they are going to kill you and the letter is with me and she said that they were extremely there is a lot of enmity and an uproar on campus regarding the trip. So, anyway, that prepared me that the reception will not be easy going back to the university.
并不认为这次旅行是一次无价的教育经历。在奥斯威辛的最后一天，我的秘书给我写了一封电子邮件，说学生们已经来到了校长办公室，他们在抗议你自己的校园，他们来并留下了一封威胁你生命的信，说你不应该回大学，如果你回来他们会杀了你，信就在我手里，她说他们非常愤怒，校园里对这次旅行有很多敌意和轩然大波。不管怎样，这让我做好了回大学后接待不会轻松的心理准备。
And once I went there, I noticed that there was a lot of enmity people were looking at me as if I have a a matrator of betrayed them. At the same time, nine student organization issued a statement on campus saying that this is normalization and normalization equals treason. Muhammad was forced to resign from his job. One night someone set fire to his car. He knew his life was in danger. He packed his bags and left Jerusalem again.
一旦我去了那里，我注意到有很多敌意，人们看着我，好像我背叛了他们一样。与此同时，九个学生组织在校园里发表声明，称这是正常化，而正常化等同于叛国。穆罕默德被迫辞职。一天晚上，有人放火烧了他的汽车。他知道自己的生命处于危险之中。他收拾行李，再次离开耶路撒冷。
This time exiled by his fellow Palestinians. I asked him how it felt to be called a traitor. What was most hurtful for me, most painful, was nobody stood by me. That was really what was most painful for me. Also, the fact that I have dedicated all my life for the Palestinian cause and suddenly I am a traitor for that cause, so that also was painful. When I talked to Muhammad, he was living in Washington, just like Avner, who is also in the United States, Muhammad hopes to go home someday.
这一次，他被同胞巴勒斯坦人放逐了。我问他被叫做叛徒是什么感觉。对我而言最伤人、最痛苦的是，没有人站在我身边。这真的是对我和最痛苦的。还有，我把一生的时间都奉献给了巴勒斯坦事业，突然之间我成了该事业的叛徒，这也很痛苦。当我与穆罕默德交谈时，他住在华盛顿，就像阿夫纳一样，他也身在美国，穆罕默德希望有一天能回家。
I want to leave you with one last note. As I was learning the stories of Avnare and Guarriaho and Muhammad Dajjani, I went to see a powerful new play called Wrestling Jerusalem. Commissioned by Ari Roth and produced by Mosaic Theatre in Washington DC, Wrestling Jerusalem is a one-man show that will travel to many parts of the country. Like Avnare and Muhammad's real-life stories, the play is about the intertwined traumas of the Nakba and the Holocaust, and the effects those traumas have on the ability of Israelis and Palestinians to empathize with one another.
我想给你们留下最后一条评论。在了解阿夫纳·格瓦里亚胡和穆罕默德·达贾尼的故事时，我去观看了一部非常震撼的新戏剧，名叫《摔跤耶路撒冷》。由阿里·罗斯委托制作并由华盛顿特区的马赛克剧院出品，《摔跤耶路撒冷》是一部单人秀，将在该国的许多地方巡演。就像阿夫纳和穆罕默德的真实生活故事一样，这部剧关于纳克巴和大屠杀交织在一起的创伤，以及这些创伤对以色列人和巴勒斯坦人彼此共情能力的影响。
Playwright and performer Aaron Davidman describes his travels in Israel and the occupied territories. You'll hear him speak as himself, and in the voices of Palestinians, and an Israeli man named Nandav. I'm looking for the number 18 bus in East Jerusalem, somewhere up the street from Damascus Gate, the Arab entrance to the old city. It's only a few blocks from the Jewish part of Jerusalem, but it feels like another world. The smell of the food vendors, language in the air, gestures of the people in the street, all so different. I can't find the bus stop, and I have a nervous feeling of being on the other side. I've been to Israel many times.
剧作家兼表演者亚伦·戴维曼描述了他在以色列和被占领土的旅行。你会听到他以自己的声音讲话，以及扮演巴勒斯坦人和一个名叫纳达夫的以色列男人的声音。我在东耶路撒冷寻找18路公交车，在老城阿拉伯入口大马士革门上方的街道某处。这里距离耶路撒冷犹太人区只有几个街区，但感觉像另一个世界。食品小商贩的气味、空气中的语言、街上人们的手势，全都如此不同。我找不到公交车站，有一种身处敌方阵营的紧张感。我去过以色列很多次。
I've never been to Ramallah. When I finally find the small bus, I pay six shekels, and I get on. I sit in the back. I'm sure I'm the only Jewish person on the bus, but I feel invisible. No one seems to pay any attention to me. The atmosphere is quiet, tired.
我从未去过拉姆安拉。当我终于找到那辆小巴时，我付了六谢克尔并上了车。我坐在后面。我确信我是车上唯一的犹太人，但我感觉自己是隐形的。似乎没有人注意到我。气氛安静而疲惫。
As soon as we get on the highway, the bus is stopped by the Israeli police. Tadduk, vaksha! I clutch my passport. I don't want to pass it forward. I just sit there. The officer doesn't see me. Now my invisibility feels conspicuous.
一上高速公路，公交车就被以色列警察拦了下来。Tadduk, vaksha!我紧紧抓着护照。我不想把它往前递。我只是坐在那里。警官没有看到我。现在我的隐形感变得显眼起来。
There's a blank stare in the eyes of the middle-aged Palestinian men as they pass their IDs forward. Do you speak English? A woman turns to me. Do they ask to see your ID? No. You see how they humiliate us. Ten minutes later, we approach the Kalandia checkpoint.
当中年巴勒斯坦男人把身份证往前递时，他们的眼中有着呆滞的凝视。你会说英语吗？一个女人转向我。他们要求看你的身份证吗？没有。你看他们是怎么羞辱我们的。十分钟后，我们接近了卡兰迪亚检查站。
There's a long line of cars and people on foot waiting to cross through. Manned by the Israeli Army, Kalandia is one of the few places to cross from Israel into the West Bank and from the West Bank into Israel. Hundreds of kilometers of electric fences, trenches, barbed organization, calls this structure the separation barrier. The Israelis call it the security fence. The Palestinians call it the apartheid wall. Whatever you want to call it, it's massive and intimidating and haunting. The Kalandia crossing is a rocky nomans land with two giant ominous watchtowers surrounded by fences laced with barbed wire.
排着长队的汽车和步行的人等待通过。由以色列军队驻守的卡兰迪亚是从以色列进入约旦河西岸以及从约旦河西岸进入以色列的仅有的几个通道之一。数公里的电网、战壕、带刺铁网，该组织称这个结构为隔离墙。以色列人称之为安全隔离墙。巴勒斯坦人称之为种族隔离墙。无论你想怎么称呼它，它都是庞大、令人生畏且挥之不去的。卡兰迪亚过境处是一片岩石密布的无人区，周围环绕着两个巨大的险恶岗楼，周围环绕着缠绕着带刺铁丝网的围栏。
Concentration camps. All I can think of is concentration camps. Concentration camps. A lifetime of holocaust imagery comes lurching forward from the back of my mind. No! Don't think of concentration camps. There's no moral equivalency here. It's not the same, it's not the same guard towers, guard dogs, barbed wire, soldiers, machine guns, refugees, suitcases, now the Jews are the guards, and I'm on the train going into the camps, and I, I, I, I, I, I, I remember Nadav and Aron, the craziest thing when I got here, I did not yet know my gilly was on this bus.
集中营。我脑子里想的全都是集中营。集中营。一生的大屠杀意象从我脑海深处猛烈涌现。不！不要去想集中营。这里没有道德对等。这不是一回事，这不是一样的岗楼、军犬、铁丝网、士兵、机枪、难民、手提箱，现在犹太人成了守卫，而我正坐着火车进入集中营，而我，我，我，我，我，我，我记得纳达夫和亚伦，当我来到这里时最疯狂的事情是，我还不知道我的吉利在这辆公交车上。
I did not know I heard on the radio of the Piguah, the bumbing, and I come right here. It's my neighborhood. In Haifa, we don't expect such things. And I stood here in the street, and I could smell burn flesh in the air, and at that moment I had this strange feeling. I thought this must be the smell, the people smelled coming off the trains in Auschwitz, the smell of the crematoriums. My parents were the only survivors of the family to make it out alive. Every other member
我不知道我从收音机里听到了Piguah，也就是爆炸，我直接来到了这里。这是我的社区。在海法，我们不期望发生这种事。我站在街上，我能闻到空气中烧焦的肉味，那一刻我有一种奇怪的感觉。我想这一定就是奥斯威辛训练营里人们从火车上下来时闻到的气味，火葬场的味道。我的父母是家族中仅有的生还者。其他所有家庭成员
of the family was killed, every single one, uncles, aunts, everyone completely destroyed and here, 60 years later. My Gilly, burn alive in Stubutal murder, he was 13 years old. He was in the peace camp for Palestinian and Israeli children just two weeks before look. I don't hate the Arabs, but build the wall, absolutely build the wall, let them live over there, and we live over here. I'm finished! And I'm staring at this wall, out the window of the bus, at the Kalandaya checkpoint, and six million ghosts chase me as we drive through and I wonder if they will ever rest.
都被杀害了，一个不剩，叔叔、阿姨，每个人都被彻底毁灭，而现在，60年过去了。我的吉利，在残酷的谋杀中被活活烧死，他才13岁。就在两周前，他还在巴勒斯坦和以色列儿童的和平夏令营里，看。我不恨阿拉伯人，但建墙，绝对要建墙，让他们住在那里，而我们住在这里。我受够了！我正盯着这堵墙，透过公交车的窗户，看着卡兰迪亚检查站，当我们驶过时，六百万个幽灵追随着我，我在想他们是否能安息。
Aaron Davidman performing an excerpt from his play, Wrestling Jerusalem. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Karam Agar-Kallison, Maggie Pennman and Max Ness Track. Our team includes Raina Cohen, René Clarre and Jenny Schmitt. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our intern is Chloe Conley. If you like this episode, please share it with friends and on social media. While you're at it, check out Hidden Brain on Facebook and Twitter. You can also hear my stories each week on your local public radio station.
亚伦·戴维曼表演他的戏剧《摔跤耶路撒冷》的片段。本期《隐藏的大脑》由卡拉姆·阿加尔-卡利森、玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯·特拉克制作。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、勒内·克拉尔和珍妮·施密特。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。我们的实习生是克洛伊·康利。如果你喜欢这期节目，请与朋友分享并在社交媒体上转发。顺便去Facebook和Twitter上关注《隐藏的大脑》。你也可以每周在当地公共广播电台收听我的故事。
Our unsung heroes this week are Jessica Hansen and Chi-Oki-I Hansen. You may not know their names, but you surely know their voices. They read the sponsorship credits for Hidden Brain and other NPR shows. Like this. Support for this Brain and other NPR shows. Like this. Support for this podcast and the following message comes from Wells Fargo. This episode of Hidden Brain and the following message is... Thank you Jessica and Shio-Ki for making us sound better every week.
我们本周的无名英雄是杰西卡·汉森和奇-奥基-I·汉森。你可能不知道他们的名字，但你肯定知道他们的声音。他们为《隐藏大》和其他NPR节目朗读赞助鸣谢。就像这样。对本脑和其他NPR节目的支持。就像这样。对本播客及以下信息的支持来自富国银行。本期《隐藏的大脑》及以下信息是... 谢谢杰西卡和希奥-基让我们的声音每周都听起来更好。
We have a request for you. From time to time as we work on new episodes, we ask for your help. For an upcoming episode, we want to explore the lives of people whose posts on Facebook or pictures on Instagram paint a very different picture from what is actually happening in their lives. Do you post happy pictures about vacations or your children's accomplishments when really your life isn't going so well? If you have a story that you're willing to share with us, please call and leave a message at 661-772-7246. That's 661-778-brain. I'm Shankar Vedanthan and this is NPR.
我们对你有一个请求。在制作新节目的过程中，我们不时会寻求你的帮助。对于即将推出的一期节目，我们将探讨那些在Facebook上发帖或在Instagram上发照片描绘的生活与他们实际生活中发生的情况截然不同的人的生活。你是否会在生活中过得并不太好时，发布关于假期或孩子成就的快乐照片？如果你有一个愿意与我们分享的故事，请打电话并在661-772-7246留言。即661-778-brain。我是香卡·韦丹坦，这里是NPR。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 本集节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。